after nearly a week of blockades at the
emerson border preventing travelers and
trade from passing through new
information from rcmp today saying an
agreement has been reached with
protesters and they're expected to head
home our abigail turner has been
following this story and joins us now
with the details abby how did rcmp come
to a resolution
lisa rcmp say they've had two
negotiators on site of the blockade for
up to 16 hours a day in a tweet this
afternoon rcmp say full access to the
emerson port of entry will be restored
trucks trailers and farm equipment has
been sitting in the middle of highway 75
for six days but rcmp said tuesday
afternoon they were able to reach a
peaceful
resolution with protesters rcmp sergeant
paul moneg says keeping conversation
open between organizers was important
so you can't go rush in there and like i
say kind of make a rest write tickets
because
you might have just cleared one area but
then you're just gonna have another
group coming in that's gonna be even
hotter
might dig their heels in more so got to
open up that dialogue
now sergeant manage says he counts this
situation as a win for the rcmp as no
arrests or charges were made police are
currently helping to coordinate
protesters departure they say they're
confident protesters and their vehicles
will be removed by wednesday
in the end we basically had to state you
know this has to end at some point and
we were kind of clear on the actions
that we were going to take
at later steps if this didn't get
resolved
now lisa right now rcmp say part of
coordinating vehicles and protesters out
is removing the massive snow piles and
drifts that have accumulated over the
past six days but officials still say
they're planning for all roads to reopen
by wednesday
global's abigail turner reporting thanks
abby